brought to you by msi computers msi
number one in gaming find out more at us
msi com let's start uh I don't know at
the start I guess yeah matter of fact
let's go for its Mass Effect Andromeda
revealed in a trailer right at the
beginning if you notice like in the
pre-show we said I drove it about five
times I think that is a conservative
estimate you guys were saying that for a
long time but yes there it is we got a
glimpse at a sort of a mass effect n7
character swiping through a bunch of
concept art but this actually looks like
it's I mean it's a teaser trailer right
but this is sort of transitions into the
navigation module yeah and then I think
those were the concept worlds that we
got to see last year as well when they
were showing conceptual prototypes of
the world they were kind of creating and
one of them had a sky whale or just some
giant creature floating through space so
definitely going to see some new
creatures in action of course i love the
redesign of the n7 armor i'm gonna say
it looks kind of it looks more alien if
anything how so i don't know just the
way it's jutting out not entirely
conforming to the shape of whatever new
Shepherd is you get a glimpse of it yeah
and actually so in that moment sort of
the jetpack scramble and now in this
moment coming up the armor does look
there's sort of a more nimble kind of
gameplay I mean you know you can always
run a shepherd but this ground pound
here there's sort of it feels like a
little bit more of a kinetic focus on
the heroes mobility and in that part as
well you could hear a Reaper sound
effect yeah when these kind of building
things were moving um so maybe hinting
because the reef that's the things like
they can't pull a Daleks on it and keep
bringing the Reapers back at every
single opportunity but I'd like to think
there was some kind of reaper influence
some kind of connection so the
technology you know because as we learn
from the Protheans and mass effect that
old technologies is kind of around and
has weird influences on the different
species of people that find it boys we
didn't see any gameplay well the holiday
2016
yeah yeah no I mean I think I think we
all thought or at least hope that it was
further along in development and it was
um I can wait I can wait anybody look
absolutely beautiful yeah was that
enough to give you a little a little
weight you know like okay yeah it's
coming looks pretty cool yeah we could
just wait before how about that Mako or
whatever the version of it that there's
that thing was quick that was like
creepy insect quick you know when you
see an insect moving like now you
shouldn't be able to do that [ __ ] do
that that was fast it reminded me a
little of the because they did have this
speedy was at the firewalker in my spec
too I was like a DLC yeah like thing and
it was speedy but obviously it was a
like it floated off the ground so this
looks like a best of both worlds North
tanky and yet nimble mm-hmm very
exciting Mass Effect Andromeda that's
our first look gotta just at the e a
press conference here at e3 2015